it's been a long year for the travel
sector
and in a third lockdown border controls
are tightening
all international arrivals including uk
nationals
will now need a negative test 72 hours
before entering england
there'll be exemptions for hauliers
cabin crew and children under 11
but passengers that break the rules will
have to pay a 500 pound fine
we'd certainly urge the government to
use this time wisely
the move brings the uk in line with many
other countries
but it's another test for consumer
confidence
we completely understand that they are
necessary but
you know it doesn't go anywhere into
support or boost consumer confidence and
that you can have
the adverse effects there's a lot of
things there for
customers to to get their head arounds
and for certainly for some people we
know it has been a barrier to travel and
so
that's why we'd certainly urge the
government to look at providing support
for the sector but also making sure that
there is a clear route out of this
with passengers already grappling with
travel restrictions and quarantine rules
holiday hope was always a long way off
and as a new strain of the virus spreads
a testing policy the government once
opposed
they now say is needed to protect the
country ali fortescue sky news